[Music]
so there's this man who was a locked
inside of a freezing and filthy uk
garden shed for 40 years and kept as a
slave
what
wow
like what did they do like let them out
to just [ __ ] work on the garden and
then they put them back in so at most he
did jobs like painting slating and
tarmacking for as little as about 10
pounds a day [ __ ]
but he was literally in a six shed with
no lights or heating for 40 years but
why pay him if he's late he's getting
paid is he just balling now what does he
spend it on yeah this is a weird time to
hope for this but please tell me he's
mentally disabled in some way
uh why would you want to hope for that
because that's the people like you know
they get taken advantage of in that way
because if he's not then it's like holy
[ __ ] but then if he is then it's like oh
that's why they were able to like can
you only do that to people they think
they're living this great life but
they're really just like like oh like
yeah but if they think they're living a
great life and maybe but
you know what it usually is it's usually
like um migrants
like they bring people over
from different countries and they have a
different standard of living so then
they don't know that like this might be
normal like where they're from but then
this this is just like it's better than
the [ __ ] grass hut that they lived in
wait are you saying that example as if
like if someone is ugly as [ __ ] but
they're blind then it's okay
but they can't see it is that what
you're saying no that's physically
disabled bart man you can still
technically feel how ugly you are oh i
don't know that
like that contour like it doesn't matter
because the other thing right like it's
like like you you're so [ __ ] ugly but
you said you can't see doesn't really
matter
i don't know try to understand that one
theory that's 130 that we're just gonna
circulate just one more example just try
one more time there's another one
i never heard i hope they're disabled
you know what are you saying like they
have a wheelchair but it's made of gold
so
no like if they have a i don't know if
uh
it's like the thing that they need
to feel the pain they don't have it
ignorance is bliss basically yeah yeah
yeah right it's like that right i don't
know where they are yeah it'll be weird
yeah like if someone [ __ ] up your hair
your hair cut but if you don't have
hands you can't even feel it
and then you're like i guess it's cool
if someone [ __ ] up your haircut that's
how i know if i got a good haircut is i
feel it all right you could feel oh i'm
like oh yeah that's tight
this angle right here is straight
like
that's a tight fade but if you don't
even got hands you're like i think it's
a tight fade that's true or if like they
got covered but they die so they can't
smell or taste anything anyway doesn't
it jokes
hey editor can we cut that part out
all right so this dude named peter
swales was initially charged alongside
his 80 year old father also named peter
swells with modern slavery offenses
but the older man had died last year
shortly before standing trial both men
had denied the charges including
conspiring to arrange or facilitate the
travel of an individual between 2015 and
2019 with a view to him being exploited
but now peter swells junior had pleaded
guilty to the offense at carlisle crown
court and awaits sentence
the case was described as harrowing by a
senior investigator who said the victim
would be traumatized for the rest of his
life how did they trap this dude in 40
years i have a question
what were what was the chores that he
did or the work that he did that he was
contracted to do for ten dollars
painting tarmacking uh how much painting
did someone say 40 years worth his
maybe at a contracting company and then
they use it
but yeah i think that's a that's an
interesting question it's like how do
you keep a guy like that in a modern
town trapped in a shed that's why i was
thinking that there's like a mental
incapacitation something there's
something that we're uh yeah i don't
know like in human trafficking right
like if it's not
if it's usually it's it's tied with the
sex trade but if it's not it's a labor
trade so like um
in
and it sucks because usually it's the
the community exploiting the their own
people
but like what ends up happening is like
let's say you you get recruits from a
poor country and then they just go i
want to go to america and work but
they're uneducated they don't know how
to get the right paperwork or whatever
you get a smuggler to basically bring
them over
and then some people they just basically
work illegally and then they go home but
then the other people who get trapped
into the human trafficking you know
slavery thing what ends up happening is
like they'll get into
like slums or like shitty situations
where they become indentured servants
which is basically slavery right and
they they could never leave because
first they don't make enough they might
not even know the language to get enough
help and then they always get threatened
because they're like well i'll [ __ ]
throw you into the streets then there's
no documents taken too yeah they hold on
to their documents if they have
legitimate like there's just [ __ ] up
so many ways they can take advantage
yeah and then like um man it's just
tough because sometimes you just don't
know if these like undocumented workers
are being traded like in that sense yeah
and held hostage because some of them
just have servants servants in the house
too that are like
doing free work and they're like well
you're here for a better quality of life
we're feeding you and that's enough
yeah does like um does like chinese or
japanese like other cultures have the
same thing because uh in filipino
culture it's kind of like a
dark problem where
uh like well-off families that migrate
to america will bring like a auntie
but she's not actually blood it's really
just like a servant
and they just do nothing but like
housework and they're they're barely
getting paid anything they live there
but as a kid you grow up thinking it's
your actual aunt and then eventually you
find out it's enough
are they happy though like are they part
of the family or no they're just they're
always treated lesser they're always
very clear so there's a there's a caste
system or servant system absolutely it's
it's basically just like trying to
operate as
as you did in the philippines but it
would be unacceptable here to do that so
then you have to make this fake like
veneer that's like an unspoken oh this
is your own there's a lot over here
because in the european union
they have a lot of uh uh class
separation right so there's a lot of
servants and people that work for these
like well to do separation of class yeah
i mean and it's also just like any any
place where there's someone well off
like it's just harder to do that in
america where you can have a live-in
servant you'd have to pay them a fair
wage but then for like in the
philippines sometimes you'll just take a
poor
family that has like a daughter that's
like oh you know what let me get your
daughter as a servant here and we'll
give her a place to live i'll guarantee
she has like a pretty good life wow and
then it's that's like a thing that
happens a lot there so when you migrate
here and you want to keep that system
you have to like put on this fake like
oh here's perfect bonus auntie yeah yeah
but then that auntie
that auntie would still be able to take
their you know seemingly lower wages for
an american standard but like in terms
of like the economic you know financial
exchange it's like being able to send
that money back to their family back
home is a good opportunity compared to
what they were doing anyway as a house
servant in the philippines you know what
i'm saying so i think japanese people
are too lazy for that because the
conversion rate is pretty similar and on
top of that like um you know if you go
to any japanese restaurant they're only
open for lunch and dinner they're like
trying to find ways not to work
as joe rolls his eyes
as he's disgusted i was trying to buy
black sesame ice cream yeah [ __ ] two
days ago
and then i was like okay i went to 168
99 ranch and then i saw
nakata market of japan on my men's
[ __ ] clothes i bet you because it was
like 702 and then close at seven of
course
okay i know the ones that probably would
have the black sesame ice cream they
went to the chinese market dude they're
like we closed but go ahead you know i
did never refuse a sale dude i went to
99 ranch but they didn't have like the
legit japanese brands yeah i never had
black sesame oil
good dude very good my sesame's good do
you like nutty flavors like hazelnut and
stuff yeah it's like that yeah dude
you're gonna love it
you know what they used to do though
like north korean food mainly though
yeah basically
happens a lot when when people are poor
right like
um what what used to happen was like so
in japan industrialized uh all the
farmers a lot of farmers lost work so
they would go in mass to like hawaii
brazil all those places and then that's
how you have these like communities out
there of like japanese in hawaii or
whatever because they weren't they
didn't even make enough to go back or
even do anything
and then also they would get um i guess
this is kind of like slavery but they
had picture bribes because the girls who
who came from poor families they
couldn't um they couldn't find a husband
so then these immigrants that went to
like america hawaii whatever at the time
hawaii wasn't a part of america
they would save up money and then it
would like it would be like old school
instagram where they would send pictures
and then they would send pictures back
and then they would arrange the marriage
[ __ ] get catfished in both ways you
know and then they would get matched up
and then they the girls can't go back
and then they're like well [ __ ] i
thought you were like a rich american
dude and then they're like i have to
[ __ ] work in the fields and you're
just a peasant too
and then so
that kind of [ __ ] went down yeah picture
brides
yeah but like nowadays i think it with
wealth it'll change countries you know
so like when if the philippines have a
bigger middle class they're probably not
going to have to deal with that kind of
slavery
yeah
yeah that's a very weird type yeah
because it doesn't feel wrong at all
like when you go up around it you just
everyone seems happy and then once you
grow up you realize like economically
damn this person this auntie never left
the house like she didn't get to go
anywhere or do anything
her life was to serve your family
absolutely damn yeah that's crazy
absolutely yeah it's weird
[Music]
[Music]
you